[Applaudissements]
sache que évidemment si nous on a tous
mis une bonne note la plus importante
c'est celle qu'on vient de voir là c'est
la note des téléspectateurs parce que
les téléspectateurs c'est eux qui feront
ou des fronts sa carrière c'est eux qui
t'aiment rond qui ne t'aiment rompt pas
et là en l'occurrence et ils ont tous
dit ce soir à l'instant on t'aime
capucine et moi ma capuche je voulais te
dire que j'ai été très très ému les
premiers instants où tu as pris la
parole
parce que moi ça m'a renvoyé aussi à mes
tout premiers prime à mettre tout
premier moment c'est dire leur et blanc
et non j'ai toujours très émouvant de
voir éclore une carrière une animatrice
ses premiers pas sur un prime en direct
avec tout ce qu'on sait je sais qu'elle
a travaillé incroyablement qu'elle a
répété qu'elle a vraiment travailler ses
dossiers qu'elle était avec les équipes
faut que tu arrêtes de te déprécier
capucine parce que régulièrement même
s'il ya du second degré même si tu te
moques souvent que toi-même crois en toi
parce que tu a de vraies capacités tu en
a sous le pied
et donc je trouvais que ce soir tu avais
vraiment été à la hauteur du cadeau que
tu avais fait cyril et comme tu en a
encore sous le pied j'ai pas pu te
mettre 10 j'ai laissé une petite marge
de manoeuvre je mets trois points de
marge de manoeuvre est donc je te mets à
très très bons sets
et
et on va dire et on me dit on m'a dit
capucine que celui qu'on aime tous le
gourou de la secte
cyril hanouna est d'accord avec les
tweets hausse il t'a trouvé excellente
[Musique]
un petit novion même rejoindre genève
vaud et autres jeunes heureux laisse sa
place parce que c'est toi la patronne ce
soir oui ben arfa sont malheureusement
ça y est c'est déjà fini déjà c'est la
pression qui vont suivre
[Applaudissements]
richard
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]